oh yeah
[Music]
here we go
trick or treat oh happy Halloween and
what do we have we have a dinosaur a
Little Red Riding has no death
Spider-Man I didn't know he wore a
propeller cap I guess Dad's on the
unemployment line this year all right
well that said but Uncle Crowder came
prepared
one for you
and one for you
where's the candy candy way better than
candy that's 100 USDA choice or higher
American beef from good Ranchers
but my mom's a vegetarian we should
probably need a costume because your
mom's the devil see most Supermarket
Meats actually comes from overseas that
means places like China that means
things like communism and listeria
listeria you don't need to worry about
that because you're not a pre-made
either way it's not an issue with good
ranchers because good ranchers Partners
exclusively with 100 American Farms
small own Farms that's how they get you
the highest quality meat Flats Frozen
delivered directly to your door at the
best prices can't say that about candy
it'll just rot your teeth and your mind
thank you you're welcome
have a good night
oh stay away from the house at 604. he's
on a watch list your parents will know
what that means
he's not supposed to live that close to
a grade school
I'm meeting with the committee
604 go to goodranchers.com Crowder for
30 off any subscription box four pounds
of American chicken and a lock in your
price no ghoulish foodborne illnesses
here just quality American meat at
spooky affordable prices
goodranchers.com Crowder boo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what I know
[Music]
[Music]
that's called The Adjustment because
Gerald a always mentions to me if I need
to adjust with the with the sometimes
you look disheveled yes
I apologize I have more money than this
one you're depending on me to make sure
you look good that's a bad idea yes
exactly oh my gosh we have a lot to get
to today look we have to discuss
something tomorrow so my question to you
right off the bat is since we'll be
discussing this tomorrow what do you
think about the left trying to you know
cancel Kanye how much of it do you think
is true how much of it do you think is
hyperbole is he too big to cancel and is
it yay or ye now here's the thing
I thought it was ye because of Yeezy yes
yes I did too ease us with anyone right
there we go yes Yeezy taught me did you
ever hear that you ever My Beautiful
Dark and Twisted Fantasy where Chris
Rock is he's like oh wait wait did you
learn to treat it mad like that easy
taught me oh my God you're wearing your
shirt with your boobs you look fine easy
taught me that was a whole like 20
minutes in the song and he's like this
is gonna be like Pink Floyd only it's
Chris Rock huh yeah and Yeezy but now
it's yay
that's what we've been talking about is
everybody's gonna be quiet
if you're in touch with Black Culture
more than Gerald I think it's kind of
since it's Kanye right it's yay Devin it
was easy I mean I don't know anything
about this
all right so uh we're going to be
talking about that tomorrow today we're
going to be talking about because this
has been By You By Request
it's been making the rounds of course as
we're dealing with OPEC right now in the
Saudis and you know them obviously
bending over our former vice president
and laughing there's this idea going
around if you look at the New York Times
if you look at Washington Post that
actually Joe Biden has increased
production of oil here in the United
States more than any other president
they even have these nice little charts
and these nice little graphs and many of
you have said Hey how do I refute this
it's very simple we'll do it today all
references available at louder.com it's
complete and total horse crap it's not I
know you're thinking is some of it it's
not even close to the realm of true I
will explain to you why all right Gerald
a how are you I would like to go buy gz
we just got a new soundboard clip yeah
not not it doesn't even try it yes I'm
doing well I'm fine except disheveled
and uh you know you love him quickest
man in the well fastest man and speak
quickest way in the west we are together
uh Nashville November 12th Ryman
Auditorium we added a second show so
there are tickets at the classic Landoll
Opera go to a lot of credit.com tour
Dave Landau Ahoy how are you what is
that shirt say it's uh it's available at
your store actually oh yeah it says due
to inflation this is my Halloween
costume oh yes I will say this Jeezy
came up with I'm kidding I want you to
buy it turn that into spandex make it a
test holiday yeah that's not too bad
some of these won't be there for
Halloween it's too late to order for
some cheesy on it yes oh geez
Monica should we call you stay oh
speaking of which we're gonna be talking
about Eric swalwell now Eric swallow
wants you to believe that women are
going to be arrested for uh having
abortions that is also a complete lie
also Meghan Markle I don't know if you
know the sociopath and she's abusive
towards her uh Royal husband but now
she's complaining that she feels as
though she's not being treated
respectfully enough as when she was one
of the briefcase broads from Deal or No
Deal yeah she thought she was going to
go on the show and do String Theory
apparently they didn't yeah yeah you're
not there to answer the questions she
just thought she would get all the money
in the briefcase yes exactly she took it
anyway
all right
so before we get to that you know John
Oliver went on his trans rant the other
day and Jon Stewart's been echoing this
remember when they told you we used to
get banned on YouTube we had a show that
was titled there coming after your
children right they want to transition
your children that's one of the Band
episodes which you can find at mug club
uh because I said this is just
fear-mongering well now John Oliver did
that now Jon Stewart did that now it's a
matter of policy from the left uh but
now we see that it's really empowered
children and parents all over the world
uh or at least they feel emboldened I
don't know if I'd use the word empowered
because of the brittle bones due to all
the hormone Replacements see for
yourself
[Music]
he has a long hair
[Music]
they just if they combine like happy
music with horrifying imagery they're
like oh yeah that was good the guy who
was the guy who jumped in the [ __ ]
burglar
no no that's the parents that uh you
know made that just rainbow Grimace no I
know I know who I believe
yeah there's nothing that could possibly
go wrong there and by the way uh I guess
they're none too concerned with the
Optics of putting a young boy slash girl
on a pole yeah no no that's not a
problem at all what what would that
sound like four years old in the first
clip right and it says four years later
I can't imagine that's more than an
eight-year-old or a nine-year-old four
yeah yeah you think the kid knows that
they're wanting to be a girl for the
rest of their life that's born a boy at
four look it's no longer it's no longer
a conspiracy on the pedophilia coming
from the left because guess what you're
allowing them to make decisions
regarding their sexual capabilities for
the rest of if they can consent to
harvesting their sexual organs they can
consent to something that will affect
their ability and their sexual
interactions for the rest it's it's not
too far of a leapable if they can
consent to that why can't they consent
to a sexual relationship
come back remember this time stamp it
it's going to happen within the next 10
years yeah guarantee it yeah and a lot
of people are up in arms about
California right now they pass something
in 2020 I think we talked about it then
about mandatory sex offender
registration for people who have
non-vaginal sex right they were pissed
off about that because it basically said
if you have gay sex you can do that if
you're with a minor but you're within a
10-year
Gap right the judge has discretion on
whether to put you on a sex offender
list or not I'm like
so a 20 year old and a 10 year old
that's the 10-year window I I think that
should be pretty automatic also in
California they remember the left was up
the arms that you would have to disclose
if you have HIV that's a partner they're
like that's that's just another way to
stigmatize people who are spreading
their hives yeah freedom and childhoods
not ruined this guy's supposed to feel
bad pumping a disease into a random
stranger what I can't believe you oh I
forgot you never made a mistake excuse
us intentionally infecting people what
are we Wuhan yes
good old California all right at least
there's a poll which brings us here to
swalwell uh this is something we'll
touch on this pretty briefly because I
want to spend some time on the the oil
issue with Joe Biden it's not even close
to being correct and boy is the media in
going into overdrive here to try and try
and carry this guy's water going into
midterms but
um noted uh Banger of Chinese spies
um in public flatulating Enthusiast Eric
swalwell he just released an ad for his
election campaign oh good watch through
your fingers
[Music]
he is weird but cute
gross
Larry Anderson yes I have a warrant for
your arrest a rest for what penal code
243 violation unlawful termination of a
pregnancy you've got to be kidding me
that that is my personal business that's
for the courts to decide the medical
records have been subpoenaed and Dr
Landry's already in custody
oh my God you you can't just you will
have to submit to a physical examination
no no no one's touching it
turn around put your hands behind your
back puts three in the kids
[Laughter]
we're just endorsing the wall here we're
just enforcing the laws
written by Steven Seagal on November 8th
stop Republicans from criminalizing
abortion everywhere
protect women's rights and freedoms
don't do this please tell me Michael
Myers pops up next door
wow yeah by the way the very next scene
is a guy in a trench coat and it's like
ah you country pumpkin cops the feds are
taking over this is our jurisdiction
damn it this is my case shut up don't
give me that juice mate the whole floor
is just covered in blood and there's
just a baby crying left yes
she reads to the spatula I don't know
what to do I don't know what to do we
had to kill the whole family yeah
I mean it makes it makes Christian film
look fantastic it does it really is it's
the pro clutching left quality
production left behind two yeah
it felt real yes I felt like I was there
yeah and by that I mean at the craft
Services table going that's [ __ ]
thank God I'm going to scale yeah of
course it's a family with a family with
two children yet you know she's got
abortions all the time yes exactly it's
more of a hobby really so okay look I
want you to just comment does anyone
actually buy this I've had to run into
this it was changed my mind if you go
back and I'm pro-life change my mind
where immediately I refute the claim
that women would be arrested and once
you explain to them no no they wouldn't
they go oh oh okay I understand but this
is what this guy is running on and by
the way
case you've gotten Eric swellball sex
with Chinese spies that's his thing
that's his reason dad he's The
Connoisseur of Chinese [ __ ]
so uh let's go the claim that they are
making okay is it Republicans
conservatives want women arrested for
having an abortion okay here's the truth
not only has that not been proposed to
any maybe you find some radicals
somewhere in some Fringe but as far as
at a legislative level or any mainstream
pro-life Advocates it has not been
proposed and it is not the law they do
not arrest women for having abortions
performed what people do believe is if
it is an estate where it is without
outside of the confines of what that
state would Define as legal abortion
that the doctor is liable here's uh
Farah Diaz Tello a senior Council and
legal director of The pro-abortion Legal
Group
it's called if when how
good name
if when how 501c3 well what kind of C3
what five one two three is if well okay
when were you Incorporated when what do
you do how son of a [ __ ] all right so
this is a pro-legal abortion group
admitting this this is what they said
states with abortion bands have focused
punishment on the providers and not
those seeking or self-managing in
abortion it is a straw man it is not
something that has ever been the case it
is not something that people are
proposing hit the like button to piss
the people off at YouTube the YouTube
overlords because they don't want people
to find this truth and it helps us out
just hit that like button this is a myth
I don't know why it's a Well I know
exactly why but it's so lazy that you
would learn this in you know abortion
debate 101. if you were actually
debating abortion and you were actually
trying to make a case for it if you were
with a professor who had any type of
experience
and critical thinking or in debating
would say well hold on a second oh you
can't actually use that because that's
not true that's right straw man oh okay
logical fallacy the first one you learn
about
and just to be clear I want to declare a
personal level I I wouldn't want that
because I will tell you this I believe
that many women are lied to and they
don't know that they're terminating a
life many women don't they're told that
it's a procedure like removing a benign
cyst I can't tell you how many people
and this is why the change my Minds get
throttled this is why we're not allowed
to advertise them on YouTube why we've
had people go to change my mind with the
pro-life issue they've looked at a fetal
chart and they have become pro-life and
then millions of people have seen these
and changed their opinion just by
showing them what an abortion is these
women are lied to many of them don't
know and that's not to say mansplaining
just like you don't necessarily know
what's happening if you're having colon
cancer removed you don't know what's
going on with a medical procedure you
often trust your doctor and you have
doctors who are predatory in their
practices who want to make you believe
that this is a medically necessary
procedure and comes with no risk to you
or the life in your womb here's another
Truth uh Eric swalwell professional
Banger of Chinese spies uh he's running
for California's 14th District and uh
keep in mind that means that none of
this matters anyway
because of Roe v wait California can
have abortion up until including birth
there's still states that do that I
think they're looking at extending it to
one year after just to make sure buyers
remorse yes right so yes just in case
you're like ah like him with the Chinese
call service so that guy just let fake
police take his wife yes pretty much yes
but they drew fake guns though Dave oh
Phil they were just male strippers who
got a taste of Godlike power
I've got a package no wait a second I
can actually strip her over rights let's
put her in the Paddy Wagon like oh wow
your methods your method male strippers
the locking doors and everything we take
our job seriously Dr steinman's already
in custody did he just do the one
abortion
States yeah it's not being proposed or
in red States and in California they
would be unaffected by this now the
babies who are aborted into the third
trimester in California are not
unaffected the women who are lied to are
not unaffected just to be clear who's
more radical again let's take the actual
radical position of the right that if a
doctor performs an abortion particularly
in a state where or let's say it's a
late term abortion outside of the
parameters of what is permissible that
has been decided upon that state that
that doctor should be held legally
liable just like a doctor performing any
other risky non-medically necessary
procedure that is the position of the
right the position of the left in places
like California in places like Virginia
is abortion up until including birth
period taxpayer funded and in Virginia
after birth well the the position of the
people in the Republican party is look
the people of your state get together
and they vote on what they want and then
it becomes law and then if you break the
law there are consequences this is how
Rule and law Works in society you get
together you decide and then you move
forward by the way speaking of lying to
women the president of Earth Stacey
Abrams lied about the fetal heartbeat to
make sure that people knew that that's
not a real thing there's not really a
heart actually there it's just
electrical signals and somebody did not
do a Google search she also lied about
her weight no yeah she recently told the
pilot she was 115 pounds yes yes really
did the plane crash no they just
wouldn't let anybody else go and they
were even generous they wrote down
kilograms and it's still with
counterweight
it flew like this sideways it was like
Sully it just flew in a circle for about
he's circling not on purpose they yelled
Birds strike but it wasn't we just need
the land the whole flight was like
Conair when I was going down
[Laughter]
tell
us
and then you want to live she's like I
want to visit the park can I see the
pilot in the cockpit the plane just
she was in Conair actually they put
Christmas lights around her and used it
was one of the casinos
they put on a spinner made her lay down
like crap stable
uh okay so here's the thing this is
fear-mongering it's not true that's the
theme of today's show these these myths
that just they're pervasive and they're
easy to debunk all references are
available at a lot of crowded.com but
they Trot them out at midterms
especially when the economy uh is at an
all-time uh awful certainly in our
lifetime because the fear-mongering
right now is just designed to say hey
vote Democrat if you don't want your
wife carried out
it's just the fact that if I say that it
sounds silly let alone to shoot a whole
sketch
but here's the thing it's dirty there's
mud slinging on both sides and we've
actually obtained an exclusive I believe
if we have it ready an exclusive ad from
swallow Wells yeah political rival
Allison Hayden and you know what I think
that that's it's more effective it's a
message we can all get behind
okay is there an inika igador off here
here hello I'm Congressman Eric
swalwell's assistant Spartacus I just
want to see are you willing to have
intimate relations with Mr swalwell
okay and are you a Chinese or Russian
spy I spy for Mother Russia Great okay
you are hired please vote for literally
anyone except Eric swalwell he has sex
with spies
a little on the nose yeah I mean it's
not incorrect yeah on the nose doesn't
mean wrong
he likes to hire twinks yes
also that's the game he plays the
Chinese place got your nose there's a
language you're like oh no
what happened he's like I'm just kidding
always so cruel
should see what he does with silver
dollars no uh he pulls them out of
places you wouldn't believe
they're tiny shoes uh it's a live show
Monday through Thursday 10 a.m Eastern
by the way if you're watching this right
now and uh nothing might be happier than
you all going over to rumble of course
mug Club where we'll be reviewing the
Creed trailer today Creed Three it's a
double show if you watch Club
letterscutter.com you get the wonderful
hint at smug they get all these other
shows and you get uh uh it's it's the
only one that keeps us afloat because as
you well know we are not monetized on
YouTube nor should we be wow what
and I'll give you a reason as to why
we're not monetized on the YouTube
what's that because of recurring
segments like this uh we're about to
talk Meghan Markle time for what a piece
of [ __ ]
[Music]
sorry I love this segment she deserves
it it's time we were asked to stop doing
it by certain powers that be by who
knock a queen yes sir by certain powers
that be uh after we did the Don Lemon
what a piece of [ __ ] okay like you can't
do that that's not very nice and I said
you're right it's not very nice and um
we're going to continue so
Tuesday's episode of the podcast Megan
and I I will say this it's like an Amber
hurt situation she is clearly a
narcissist and I feel bad for Prince
Harry he's very clearly not happy oh no
he's very clearly being controlled in
this relationship uh he's sad and this
what she does she seems to be
gaslighting where she's a Perpetual
victim she's alienating him from
everyone who's been a support structure
his entire life so anyway
she has to be a victim in order to try
and throw you off the scent Markle in a
funny way lamented about how she was
treated like a bimbo and she wasn't
valued for her brains when she was I
believe a briefcase lady right do I have
that right she was yes she was a
briefcase bro hold on a professional
briefcase opener right yes yes and
that's the lowest of the low like you're
not you're not even doing The Price is
Right showcase like that's the Pinnacle
yeah well In fairness she has to
remember what number she is and then
opened the briefcase when called right
and that's they still pre-taped because
they usually get it wrong well yes she
keeps opening hers every time I said I
said 13. oh is that eight not a three
and if she shakes hands with Howie
Mandel he'll wash them until he bleeds
yes well that's anybody and he has his
white Suge Knight dangle you from a
balcony yes so she was upset that she
wasn't appreciated for her brain yes
sugar night
sugar nightly that's so bad
not for her brains
I I mean I this is coming out of my
mouth but it's trending like I don't
know why but this is a surprising of
some people taking her side as though
yeah she's being a she's being
objectified well yeah yeah you're not
being objectified but you are being
treated as a model which is kind of
objectification so here she is in her
podcast complaining about her not being
appreciated for her brains but only her
body on the set of Deal or No Deal and
there were times when I was on set
at Deal or No Deal and thinking back to
my time working as an intern at the U.S
embassy in Argentina and Buenos Aires
and being in the motorcade the Secretary
of Treasury and being valued
specifically
for my brain yeah because that's what
you value interns for yeah I was being
valued for something quite the opposite
I mean you have to imagine just to paint
the picture for you that before the
tapings of the show all the girls we
would line up and there were different
stations for having your lashes put on
or your extensions put in or the
question is necessary to Showcase your
brains we were even given spray tan
vouchers each week
because there was a very cookie-cutter
idea of precisely what we should look
like it was yeah it's called a show yes
and not necessarily about brains could
you imagine her as an extra on like
Battlefield Earth like when I gotta wear
blue makeup and yes yes imagine you go
see the Blue Man Group and just some guy
shows up like powder you're like that's
not the costume you saw auditioned for
this you stood in line with other people
and said please pick me for the job yeah
like you went out to get the job and
somebody said you know you are very
attractive I think the camera loves you
and uh she was like I can't believe it
world I have to live in imagine if LeVar
Burton came into Star Trek one day he's
like I feel like with this people can't
see me no one asked my opinion yes
you're you're an intern by the way an
internship is where you actually learn
to do stuff interns typically are asked
to do very low no no here was her job on
dealer no deal we actually have a clip
yeah yeah this is her doing her job
okay clapping that's hard it's difficult
[Applause]
oh he even knew her name
[Music]
and she didn't even get she didn't even
get to do her quantum physics oh that's
what she had before she met the prince
no no actually I think this uh helped
launch her career oh into meeting a
prince yes pretty much you mean into
infiltrating his circle of friends and
deliberately moving her way up and
finding out who could connect her with
the prince correct before she got him
under her spell no that's when she met
Mike on suits working for the law firm
so well that's right she was on that
show soon yeah yeah do you notice that
all the women there look the same they
look pretty simple you notice they're
all wearing the same outfits hey I don't
know if you know this when men play
sports they wear a team jersey what are
we a piece of meat I know it's crazy
Howie Mandel same outfit just in the
male version of it right yes
oh my gosh she was so mistreated can you
imagine listening to this podcast well
an idiot just tries to sound smart well
she was talking with Paris Hilton oh
well then I stand corrected people just
it's like people only view me for my
body well maybe it's because you got
entirely famous through a sex tape that
you actually know no that's not it it's
because you are sexist I don't know I
think it might be because I've seen your
privates and I didn't ask to I don't
know maybe it's because you were on a
fox show where you went around American
belittled anyone who wasn't extremely
rich yes with Nicole Richie yes uh you
yeah that's that's fair so you milk the
cow that's where milk comes from
what's this is a real quote what's
Walmart do they make walls like I don't
know I'd like to drive you through one
yeah it sure sounds a real quote I mean
I realize Nicole Rich has grown up from
that and yeah Hilton is too but so he
said not somebody you don't really have
to act smarts in front of Paris Hilton
no you you don't really have to ask if
you should just be smarter Paris Hilton
doesn't have to act smart in front of
Paris Hilton here's the thing these even
though it really is it's women taking
advantage of opportunities right she
chose to go and then afterwards
complaining about it and and accusing
you of being sexist or discriminatory
for hiring someone like this to do
exactly what it is they sought to do
that's what it is and by the way you
notice there aren't nearly I would love
to as someone who was working you know
and as an actor for a very long time of
course I wouldn't make the cut if it was
a modeling but the point is I would have
loved to have had that opportunity to
Simply stand get scale to open a
briefcase you need to pay the bills it's
better than waiting tables yeah but men
typically aren't used as models unless
it's a novelty and women laugh at you
when you do Chippendales which they
don't take seriously because a wiener is
a silly thing let me tell you this on
the side did you know yesterday we had
to go pee outside yes right because the
toilets are down they're back up thank
you small miracles now I wish someone
told me yesterday no they weren't up
yesterday I'm kidding but I realized so
we all we all agree we all peed outside
right yeah I didn't okay I have not peed
outside uh I realized I don't think ever
in like full daylight usually you're in
the woods or maybe it's night time right
or it's like you know your friend's
sleeping in a party
yeah but in full broad daylight raking
across your John Thomas it is a very
very horrendous looking apparatus oh
yeah it's not pleasing no you're looking
like that's not even the same color as
the rest of your body no Stephen
Crowder's juicy balls no
it's just I had that realization I have
never looked at this part of me in the
Sun and there's a reason
I don't need to no and then if you if
you didn't shower that morning or you
went for a jog you're like oh my God
this is no good yeah I don't think it
should affect its appearance that much
it's just one shower skip that sounds
like more of a life no no I mean I mean
the odor in the breeze a series I'm not
saying you should smell it outside
but if you're inside you know what I
mean yes yes I don't so yes you do here
is Mark I don't smell yours no no that's
because you actually you were peering
through the door well
that one's called he installed a sniff
he installed a sniff hole in the
bathroom oh that's it's just bizarre
yeah all right so here's the thing this
isn't the first time Markle has tried to
go out and and play the victim yeah um
and this is the problem right is is
someone who treats people poorly and
it's on the record that she treats
people poorly it's on the record that
she doesn't make very good decisions she
seems to be rubbing a lot of people the
wrong way and it can never be her fault
like we've talked about with the left
you're dealing with narcissists you're
dealing with clinical narcissism just uh
on on a massive scale and now let's
shrink it back down that you're dealing
with a Meghan Markle like an Amber Heard
type so some examples of it's never her
fault uh it's your fault or their fault
it's Deal or No Deal's fault it was the
Royal Family's fault because they're all
racist Megan claimed at least one member
of the family had concerns about how
dark their son's skin would be there are
several conversations there's a
conversation with you with Harry
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like I don't believe it because you
are basically white looking and he's
really white looking and who's that
woman the great great slave grandchild
of Thomas Jefferson right yes yes
talking about Oprah
[Laughter]
I don't believe it and if and of course
it's something that can never be claimed
it's something that can never be proven
right it's just I make the claim they
were racist they didn't want the kids to
to be dark and then the royal family
can't defend themselves she also claimed
that he and Harry were mistreated at the
Queen's funeral right that was a more
recent one yeah she complained about not
getting paid for her first Royal tour I
can't believe I'm not getting paid for
this
um a royal family yeah
but yeah you turned down your paycheck
of everything right exactly you guys had
billions of dollars coming your way at
some point that's like royal family
stepdaughter alimony yeah I do
unbelievable I never wanted to be a part
of this family anyway I'm leaving oh
well I guess that's one less mouth to
feed I'm still one I still want to take
half oh no she's she's been steeped in
American devotional I can only imagine I
I just don't want to be a prince a
princess anymore I'd be like all right
bye you were a princess for like a day
hey I'll tell you what I'll pay you
child support because you're gonna
pitching and child and that's only
because I can't pay [ __ ] support
you're only at my funeral because I
wasn't awake yes
I didn't want you there I'm just hoping
someone who's to say on so I can rise
and strangle you right here with my blue
blooded imbren my old fingers
I have syphilis under my hair
and I know you have it from him oh I
just hope that she haunts Meghan Markle
in her dreams oh I know right Queen
Krueger and her silly hats yes and her
Yorkies she left and then said I'm not
being paid for the Royal tour because
you decided to leave and by the way
tried to force your husband to leave and
excommunicate his family it's cult-like
it should also be noted that Markle uh
herself she's been accused of bullying
the palace staff it's well known that
she doesn't treat people very well sort
of like James Corden here's one staff
member and this is all allegedly every
10 minutes I had to go outside to be
screamed at me by her and Harry it was I
can't believe you've done this you let
me down what were you thinking it went
on for a couple of hours so she's
complaining about dealer No Deal job she
wanted okay they mistreated her okay
decided to leave the royal family right
but the Roy I wasn't paid as part of
this Royal Tour all right by the way the
royal family is racist and then when
there were people in the media who said
hold on a second I don't really know if
you should be throwing out accusations
of racism because we're not seeing that
she said the media was racist it's never
her fault it's always your fault tell me
again about toxic masculinity there you
go
toxic femininity toxicity you know who
really hates the dealer No Deal thing
all the the women that did not make the
cut I thought you're gonna say Jews oh
no no
I'm not sure where that came from
they're probably sitting like I got how
he met well I guess how Mandel is Jewish
is Jewish yeah
he's like helping him no this helped
launch her career by the way it's like
he's tries to negotiate the price that's
in the brief briefcase like how he is
we've already settled this like I think
we can do better
what if it was if if that briefcase was
uh 12 000.
it's 14. that's blowing up a glove yes
oh I almost forgot by the way
Divine in the oil situation here uh good
ranchers you tell the commercial I just
made the best steak of my life the other
night really yeah I need to show people
how to do it I did it in a stainless
steel pan all clad I kind of sprung for
it but go to goodrantries.com Crowder
use a promo code you can use a promo
code Crowder you get 30 off any
subscription box and right now they're
giving you four pounds of chicken it's
American Meat delivered uh they work
with small American Farms it's it's
really it's good stuff that chicken is
fantastic by the way so yeah I don't eat
a lot of chicken but it is good very
very good all right
um and I I need them to send me more
steak I eat a lot that's all I eat now
well there's actually a shortage of beef
right now not for this guy and it's uh
probably because of that guy yes no well
no it's one of the perks that's my
nickname I don't have to be out there
beefless like you plebs
it'd be racist if they didn't send you
exactly let's just try and use her all
right Megan Markle gets all the beef she
wants yes oh geez I don't think that
works that way no idea can't you just
have she complains about it it's like
this can get me real I don't because it
comes in rain sounds I want the animal
to hurt yes
it tastes better yeah yeah bring it to
the table I want to send it in the cage
being pulled apart yeah oh geez wow and
put lemon on it
we're here to arrest you because oh
sorry that's the abortion house that's
next door continue torturing your
animals at the dinner table it's like
hibachi grill with animal torture all
right someone looked at me like I was
attractive
[Music]
I'll never walk right again okay Joe
Biden former Vice President Joe Biden
right now this is going on there's a lot
going on with oil with energy this is
one of the things that affects you most
right Americans at the pump that's a big
part of what determines election certain
certainly midterms they really are
trying to Pivot away from that and make
it about abortions you just saw from uh
Eric banging Chinese spies as well well
that being said they've had the media
carry their water and uh try and
propagate these myths out there and I
know a lot of you have asked uh how to
refute these so comment below if this is
something that you've heard that you've
had to deal with and if it's helpful you
know I try and pick these topics based
on what is helpful to you and we love to
hear what it is that you would like like
us to address next because if we're not
helping you then you know there's no
reason to really do this so um
here's the the just kind of the briefers
the OPEC plus member OPEC plus OPEC plus
I hate clubs it's OPEC producing okay
whatever what what do you want to call
it I just don't like the Plus
everything's plus Disney plus apple plus
lgbts leather pluses yes thank you very
much can you just say OPEC and we'll be
like yeah we understand there's more I
don't even like pluses on my batteries
nope they're both negative well that's
my house is very dark
out of one word
um so the OPEC members they just
unanimously approved a plan to reduce
oil production by two million barrels uh
per day and what does that do of course
that's that's going to assure that
prices are likely going to go up okay
wait OPEC made the decision uh in spite
of Biden's request that they postpone
the cut specifically until after the
midterms we talked about that yesterday
it's confirmed right because Biden does
not care about you
he just says let's just punt it till
after midterm so we talked about that
yesterday go and watch that segment
here's the thing this problem right now
that you're dealing with at the pump
it's gas prices it's one of the few
issues where presidents can have a
direct impact right there is sometimes a
rubber band effect in the policies don't
really come into player I should say the
net effect of the policies for a couple
of years gas prices especially in an
industry that is so subject to I mean
for forgive the redundancy as far as
this phrase sounds
um uh uh speculators it's subject to
speculators yeah subject speculators
that works fine subject to speculators
we're really just one executive order or
honestly one press conference can change
the industry because people are hopeful
that they're going to drill and that in
essence uh creates you know some kind of
speculation that there will be more
reserves that will be available it it's
very volatile because it is based
largely on hearsay and the president can
change the environment in which the oil
the fossil fuel industry all energy
industry operates so those guys are
betting on the future price of all yeah
the president understands every time he
comes out just like when the FED comes
out and kind of hints that they may
raise interest rates it affects the
markets exactly right this is the same
thing for the president affecting gas
prices so let's look at how this is
exactly a problem from former Vice
President Joe Biden and the lies that
you've been told and how easy they are
to debunk so let's go back in time
really quickly let's go to then
during the final presidential debate uh
2020 I believe it was a final debate if
I'm not mistaken don't hold me to it
could have been one of the 19. uh former
Vice President Biden he said in and when
I say on no in no uncertain terms just I
ask that uh you know you you say well
hold on a second be skeptical of me and
then listen to him say it
word for word he said he was going to
shut down the fossil fuel industry 2020.
I have one final when he closed down it
falls would you close down by the way I
have a transition from the oil industry
yes oh I will transition it is a big
statement because I would stop because
the oil industry pollutes significantly
I see here's the deal
well if you let me finish this I'm a big
man because it has to be replaced by
renewable energy over time over time and
I'd stop giving to the oil industry I'd
stop giving them Federal subsidies and I
think we also have that that clip of him
talking to someone on the campaign Trail
remember saying yes I'm going to put an
end to the fossil fuel industry so he
reiterated several times so that's him
back then just to be clear oh that's a
big statement don't you left I know
that's a big statement that's a big
that's a big statement that's really big
wow it's pollution so what are you going
to get oil from oh countries that really
don't care about pollution at all nailed
it because that brings us to now wow
thanks for the layup Dave
former vice president is literally
threatening Saudi Arabia four wait what
what what what
cutting oil production
disappointment and uh we're looking at
what alternatives we may have
there's a lot of Alternatives
and I am uh in the process when the when
the uh this house in Senate gets back
they're going to have to uh there's
going to be some consequences for what
they've done with Russia what kind of
consequences Menendez says suspend all
arm sales is that something you'd
consider
I'm not going to get into what I'd
consider and what I'm having mine but
there will be there will be consequences
I'll tell you what he has in mind
that's it that's it he answers every
question like a movie cop that doesn't
want to tell you there's a serial killer
on the list right exactly but he's just
like no look we don't have any
information at this time we can either
confirm nor deny that's happening lock
your windows and stay inside why I can't
tell you that
there's no reason to be alarmed yes
there's nothing to see here no trouble
at all no trouble at all it's exactly
when you should Panic what about
Venezuela he's just like I've I've never
even heard of it well let's think about
this for a second Saudia he's mad now he
wanted to transition away from fossil
fuels now he's mad that Saudi Arabia is
cutting oil production right we're
talking about Alternatives so right away
we already know an alternative to
American oil production was Saudi Arabia
right we don't need we would never need
if we just actually accessed our own
energy maybe it's Venezuela you think
they have the same environmental
standards that we do here in the United
States folks what about China and coal
we can be a net this is something we
don't think about we can be a net
exporter of energy what about these
other countries that are using dirtier
forms of energy like China with coal
other uh countries that are extracting
oil basically using archaic methods we
could help them improve
their drilling practices their energy
practices to make them more eco-friendly
but we can't do it because we're
dependent on their energy to get to us
so this is also just proof positive it's
about the midterms he does not care
about you the United States of America
he wants to appeal to his base in a
general say I'm going to shut down the
fossil fuel industry he knows for well
that'll hurt you then going into the
midterms well let me alleviate the the
pain for the average American who I
don't care about any other time of the
year
punt it until after the midterms and
then we'll come right back to square one
you don't matter it's not about just
Democrat it's about the Elites in power
they know that it'll affect you after
the midterms now let's get into a Biden
would actually he wants you to believe
that he improved the oil industry in
America even though he said he would
transition away from him now he wants to
take credit
for oil production have you seen this
right I have yeah this is one of the
biggest lies that the White House has
spun yes and by saying something by
White House every major press Outlet yes
so this is something that you've
requested uh from me quite a bit uh so
here's the claim that you see going on
out there that uh gas and oil in the
United States right in the permit
specifically that they've actually
increased under bite because if you say
well oil prices are higher why don't we
access our own oil they say actually
Biden's done more for oil and gas than
any other president so you're that's a
strong no no hold on a second they're
lying but here's according to Yahoo the
federal government has been issuing oil
and gas drilling permits more willingly
than it did during President Donald
Trump's first three years in office
that's key first three years and it
could be issuing even more of the oil
and gas industry weren't leaving many
current leases undeveloped okay so
they're saying more under Biden he's
actually done more than Donald Trump
here's the truth
the permits issued in 2021 were for
leases that were sold mostly almost
entirely under Donald Trump oh and in
2022 the new permits plummeted
so in other words he was enjoying an
effect from Donald Trump that he was
publicly he can go back to that debate
he was attacking Donald Trump for those
leases that created the bump frame which
he now is claiming credit for so
production just a human idea for oil it
plummeted by 55 percent from 2021 to
2022 the numbers 2021 3 800 2022 1700.
so he comes into office there are all
these leases they've increased under
Donald Trump they were permitted under
Donald Trump takes advantage of them
then Cuts them but he's taking credit
for that first year
that's brilliant
now let me let me undergird this a
little bit here's another truth in case
you don't believe what I'm telling you
all of ref all the references are
available at lettuce cutter.com Trump's
highest average month
or sorry the highest sort of average of
the monthly permits I should say uh in
2020 it was higher than Biden's 20 21
average
so you had a huge you had a spike you
look at the trend okay 2020 monthly
average 452. we're talking about these
permits 2021 333. and then of course it
went down dramatically after that so it
was a ramp up there was a benefit from
the ramp up and then Biden screwed it up
and they want to take credit for that
first year of ramp up while it was
tapering down well and the big thing
here is look at the policies from these
administrations and the effects that
those policies have under Joe Biden if
he has his way this trend continues
right the trend after Trump continues
and he can no longer take credit for
anything but he's going to transition us
don't worry because everything's going
to run on electricity which is powered
by coal because wind and solar cannot
lift that weight and I thought
electricity was powered by other
electricity ah yes no Tesla should say
coal powered on the back of them you
were all living a lie are you saying
that the electric car doesn't charge by
electricity no it I just assumed that
electricity came from electricity what
if uh but it comes from something that
produces electricity what about the key
kites sunshine and farts I just thought
it was a bunch of Spencers plasma balls
in a warehouse
I thought it ran on Elon musk's
nightmares yep yeah but they're very
high powered your guess is as good as
mine we don't know I guess we'll never
solve the mystery of where electricity
comes from go ahead under Donald Trump
if he was in a second term right now we
wouldn't care what Russia was doing nope
we wouldn't care at all it would have
you ever checked on us to be like oh
Russia you guys want to act up over
there OPEC you guys want to cut for I
don't give I have no shites left to give
because we just produce all of our own
stuff here so you know you can buy ours
if you want just like you just did with
uh former Vice President Joe Biden that
debate like oh that's a big statement
that would be the exact same approach if
Putin says we're going to cut off supply
of oil oh that's a big statement big
moves Russia I'm shaking in my boots I'm
literally shaking and when I say
literally excuse me what I say literally
I mean that I'm frankly not shaking and
he's like on the front lawn yes to go
inside he's like oh I said the guy again
I don't want yes he makes me eat
hamburgers it's long stable he's An
Inspector Gadget helicopter
[Laughter]
all right
yeah we didn't worry about Putin
remember no we didn't right now CNN what
Biden to release another 15 million
barrels from strategic Reserve I think
we had 12 million yesterday the day
before 40 million something like that so
we're just dipping back admonish us we
were wrong we were right now we're wrong
it's a second one I think it's on top of
it yeah I know but it's either way I
just want to cut this off at the past
because tomorrow will be wrong because
he'll release more oil like he's like
he's Tyra Banks handing out Vaseline
bottles this was a double admonish
that's it's times two admonish well no I
mean hey do any of you remember ever CNN
praising Donald Trump for opening up oil
leases ever ever ever let alone the last
election can you remember any instance
where CNN focused on gas prices or
focused on how much more access we had
to our own energy under Donald Trump was
that ever a topic let alone right now
the main headline on CNN in case you
didn't actually but go ahead and bring
it up there to him in case you didn't
believe that CNN was carrying the water
so is ABC NBC CBS for this
Administration you would never see that
because oil bad Donald Trump in the
pockets of oil yeah well and right now
they're saying that Joe Biden is
reducing the price of gas and it's like
oh well that's great it's actually
coming down it's still incredibly High
don't play the game that Joe Biden wants
you to play on inflation where he's like
it only went up point two percent it's
like calls were they trick Suburban
white [ __ ] by marking something a
hundred dollars up to 300 and then
giving you 40 off it's true it's sixty
dollars to fill up a basic sedan yeah
that's not a good thing
well
it could be a good thing well I mean I
guess if you're on the oil side of it
exactly I have a diversified portfolio
yeah and by that I mean I take calls
from Putin on oil and Bitcoin why aren't
you in ethereum now hit the like button
right here as we go through another myth
uh because this is
this is important you see it right now
in real time don't you just love it when
we're budding thing and then they're
trying to do it during real time here's
another claim that they're making not
just as it relates to leases but and
you're seeing this right now Joe Biden
is actually former Vice President Biden
is producing more oil than than any
modern uh presidents previously
including president Trump some I know
have made the claim that this
Administration is in the way of domestic
production because you are but the
numbers here are inarguable we are now
at close to record levels of oil
production here in the U.S averaging now
12 million barrels a day
under this president the president the
country is producing more oil on average
than it did during the bush Obama or
Trump administrations okay so here's the
truth okay in 2020 oil production
reached an all-time high of more than 13
million barrels per day underdog
if we can make cars run on garbage from
all the stuff she had shipped over from
Canada and buried in Michigan we're in
luck yep that's not kind of high all
time high
the average the press secretary is
trying to talk about is from again
former Vice President Biden's what what
first year and a half in office so if
you're comparing the averages of the
first year and a half
the first year and a half of Biden okay
Donald Trump comes in let me just
explain this to you really quickly okay
you have this overlap Donald Trump comes
in we have eight years of Barack Obama
slash former Vice President Joe Biden it
was very anti-oil was very anti-energy
drilling went down okay Donald Trump
comes in reverses that takes a little
while to ramp up you look at his last
two three years right the first year he
just had to actually put some policy
into place boom we hit all-time highs
then reverse it former Vice President
Joe Biden comes in he's benefiting from
the policies of Donald Trump and then
plummets it so they're taking a year and
a half average of Biden versus the four
years of Donald Trump let's look at the
total at the four-year total as a matter
of fact let's just compare the second
half of Biden's presidency yeah to the
second half of trump they deliberately
avoid the and this is something I hope
that you guys do and you hear me doing
this too when I work with our
researchers I go give me an Apples to
Apples comparison yeah so when I give
you a comparison I try and say there's X
percent increase versus X percent
decrease or there's a four times
increase in the likelihood versus a two
times less like I try and make sure that
you see a percentage and a percentage or
a multiple and a multiple or a fraction
and a fraction so it's consistent
because it's very very easy to trick
people and when you say we're comparing
four years of Donald Trump including the
first year the first year where there
was an effect from Barack Obama to one
and a half years of Biden that's how you
come up with a lie something completely
irrefutable we reached an all-time high
period under Donald Trump as far as oil
being produced under his presidency of
all time yeah and by the way just again
I want to go back to this it's his
policies once they take effect that's
the question that every reporter should
be asking okay I understand what you're
saying right now this is a carryover
from the past administration your
policies are actually cutting this we
have graphs we have charts everything is
going down and to the right that's a bad
sign where will we be in two years right
because of your policies don't tell me
what Donald Trump's policies have
produced in your Administration you're
trying to do something different you
said it you wanted to do something
different to Donald Trump where will
that put us well yeah has it ever been
this level of blame the previous guy
well well in this case he's trying to
take blame the previous guy for
everything wrong and takes credit for
credit for it too that's what I mean
like yeah you know what it's always been
going on this is why I say there was
never real journalism yeah go back and
look uh the first couple years of Ronald
Reagan after dealing with the disaster
that was Jimmy Carter oh man where
people try and blame him for inflation
people would try and blame him for you
know your dollar purchasing power being
uh significantly lower then look at the
totality of his presidency he had to
come in and change a lot now it's not
like Barack Obama who in year seven and
eight was still blaming George W bush
while taking credit you could go back
and read articles from the media blaming
Ronald Reagan within the first few
months that he came into office
of the issue that were clearly set by
Jimmy Carter that's what they're doing
here only trying to take credit for the
tail end of Donald Trump again this is
one thing it's very easy to trick you I
ask that you do this next time you vote
you go okay
eight years of Barack Obama
okay really three years of Donald Trump
let's admit the fourth year was kind of
a wash because of the the pandemic and
the planned lockdowns they're into
trying to win the election but you have
eight four and you're gonna have four
eight four and four one of these things
is not like the other you can never
again claim that you didn't have
contrast that you didn't have an example
Our Generation didn't have that the
closest we had was George W bush who was
never a conservative he was a big
government Republican we all know that I
don't think he's a bad man I don't think
he was a great president you now have it
remember this let's go down to another
claim uh that uh former Vice President
Joe Biden's Administration made that
shutting down the Keystone XL pipeline
didn't affect oil prices this is nothing
they want to tell you we're making more
oil we have more leases than ever and
that's a [ __ ] it's a red herring
that the Keystone XL pipeline is it has
anything to do with oil prices okay
here's the truth all references
available at lot of credit.com the
pipeline could have delivered 830 000
barrels of crude per day by 2023. more
Supply almost always results in lower
costs in a free market I know what
you're going to say you're going to say
oh most of that was actually just crude
and it was going to go it was Canada it
was going to okay hold on a second
didn't we just yesterday hear former
Vice President Joe Biden talking about
the global economy and inflation across
the board yeah right so so even if
that's the case and it's not entirely
the case we would benefit from it
directly
still that would be better if it's
better for the rest of the world then
it's better for the United States of
America you're the one who thrusts us
into a global economy as it relates to
oil yeah but by the way if you can blame
OPEC for cutting Supply right and that's
a bad thing and it's going to make oil
prices go up and gas prices go up
wouldn't increasing Supply be a good
thing and make oil prices go down and
gas prices go down right you can't have
it both ways most of that's going to be
Canada and hold on a second you're
talking about Global Supply yes let me
again read that number to you 830
000 barrels you have crude oil per day
we would care about 50 percent less
about opec's decision if this pipeline
was up and running by next year easily
and keep in mind again let's compare
that with the all-time high 13 million
barrels of oil per day right under
Donald Trump that's actually I know it
doesn't sound like a ton but guess what
with 13 830 000 if you have that on that
still is significant that's not nothing
certainly on a global skill that is a
significant amount of energy yeah
absolutely and and I don't remember
exactly what the number was but I think
it's somewhere between 15 and 20 million
barrels per day that the United States
uses in oil consumption right so this
this is a big deal right when Joe Biden
releases 15 million barrels or 14
million barrels whatever the number is
today tomorrow when we get admonished
again that doesn't even cover a day
folks right so we have we have this
overall effective of Not only would uh
opening the Keystone XL and by the way
sometimes people get to Keystone don't
be tripped up by this Keystone versus
Keystone XL different
um Keystone already exists I won't get
super nerdy on that we'll do another day
just don't want to get tripped up make
sure you use the term Keystone XL okay
Not only would it increase the supply
which would benefit everybody but again
going back to how the oil industry Works
which this Administration admits by
simply threatening Saudi Arabia again
we're dealing with speculators canceling
the pipeline of Keystone XL when you
have businesses who are looking at many
many many many many years before they
have before the level ever turn a profit
this signals to energy companies do not
invest also the reason that energy
companies might not invest they've sort
of in a soft way uh been single to not
invest when Joe Biden says I'll shut you
down so you better not invest yeah
that'll do it
you know I know he's he's there's Nuance
you kind of have to read between the
lines it's it's not direct yeah now
again if you say well hold on a second
it's not that much but hold on but
didn't allow keys don't let's say
Keystone XL is all for Canada it only
benefits Canada all right okay let's go
with that then why would he allow
Nordstrom too
about something go through where where
Russia to Germany the Baltic regions
yeah yeah no not here in North America
but sure we'll sign off on Nordstrom too
again you do have to ask yourself is it
idiocy or when every single policy that
is enacted by this President harms the
American people while assisting foreign
sometimes adversaries but certainly
people who don't have American best
interests at heart and certainly should
not be more important to the president
than the American people oh no wait
that's nationalism you're racist if I
say hey Keystone XL hey we should allow
all of our onshore drilling we should
allow all of our drilling here we should
allow Drilling in Alaska we should allow
ourselves fracking uh but I don't think
we should have anything to do with
Nordstrom too no no that's nationalism
that's racist don't worry they'll
probably support blowing it up at some
point in the future if we haven't yes
yes yes
by the way U.S oil consumption it's a
little bit higher even daily oil
consumption is 19.89 million barrels and
it was somewhere around that number but
I didn't want to get it insane and 14 of
those barrels are just just lizzo's
servants as they clean her with a
stridgel
she's like the guy in Dune that's how
she recharges every day
[Music]
I'm sorry that's a lot of avocado we use
19 billion or million million okay I was
gonna say a billion seems like a lot
that does seem like a lot that would
seem like too much but it's so hard now
because everything's just a rounding air
billion trillion it's all trillion these
days folks here's another claim that
they'll make that Biden is helping uh
all of us by releasing 15 million
barrels from the Strategic reserves okay
here's the truth right now because of
where we are 15 million barrels is not
enough because of how much we've reduced
our capacity yeah by an entire sell-off
of 160 million barrels from the reserve
has changed the price of gas by about 40
cents
and that's insane that's a quarter of
the reserve by the way so if the reserve
also be more important to us than you
screwing up as president yes you would
think so yeah because it's for that you
know when we really need oil really
badly need oil by the way so what is
that was 40 cents on his entire sell-off
yeah you understand that for for every
ten dollars the price of oil goes up per
barrel that's a 24 or 24 Cent increase
at the pump so basically what OPEC just
did is going to raise the price they
estimate by about 11 12 bucks which cuts
into everything that he just did
basically it's a 16 Cent difference so
get ready for gas prices to go right
back up it didn't do anything except
depleta reserves Joe right thanks
appreciate that
couldn't possibly be necessary it's the
difference of long-term uh policy
designed to strengthen the American
people the American uh American Energy
period American Energy Independence
versus short term as we know we know on
the record short-term political game
before midterms this is not someone who
wants us to be energy independent they
don't they've said so
you may not like President Trump and by
the way the left who doesn't like
President Trump they would say we hate
president Trump because yes sure he's
brought down the price of gas but it's
because look at all of the increase in
drilling look at what it's going to
destroy our environment now these same
people want you to praise Joe Biden who
just wants to take it down enough before
the midterms so they can screw you
afterward
for all the same reason that people have
criticized Donald Trump is the same
reason that gas prices are through the
roof and it's the same reason that we
might enter into a global conflict the
scale of World War III you understand
this right if you rely on shitty I don't
understand someone explain this to me
can you maybe comment below maybe this
is lost on me because it's one of those
things like Charter Schools where I am
not able to find an answer
the left says and by the way not a fan
of Putin just to be clear Russia evil
shitty there is no Nuance whatsoever we
should be involved we need to go to
where Russia is awful bad okay
and we should be reliant on them for oil
you can't say Russia bad and then but we
have way more oil than Russia is Saudi
Arabia terrible right Michael Moore 911
terrorists right okay good shut down our
oil production no one there's no one out
there right now none of these critics by
the way you don't like the fossil fuel
industry not one of them will argue that
we right now could transfer to Green
energy meaning solar wind none of them
it can't be done
so okay Russia bad then you need to
follow the policy of making sure that we
are not dependent on bad people
I don't know I don't know how these
positions I don't know how they're how
they're reconcilable I guess we've just
gone down on your crack dealer it's more
about getting the crack than really
liking the dealer there's really no
other way I can put that no I think
you're absolutely right and my point is
we should have our own crack uh crack
house
it should look like what was that show
Union Jack yeah all the ladies without
the tops on that's right like that check
under Putin's tit he's got a he's got
some crude underneath there yeah we got
a whole Factory underground and we're
just letting it sit there just a bunch
of naked Russians yep
check under them skirts or the wire
whatever whatever show where they're all
naked American Gangster New Jack City
that's right new decks I think I said
Union American no American Gangster has
it as well that's true yeah the point is
if you make drugs Frank Lucas heroin if
you make drugs you do it naked if you're
a team player exactly now here's another
truth yes don't be sneaking barrels out
under the tips
are you Donkey Kong here's another truth
the Strategic Reserve is supposed to be
what what one for war time it's like an
emergency food supply it's for
emergencies hi George this is a
self-induced wound a self-inflicted
wound we do not need to be dipping into
our strategic reserves we certainly
wouldn't if we continue the policy of
Donald Trump and every day was an
all-time record high pumping of oil
so by taking the oil from the reserves
Biden is threatening our national
security how do I well the Strategic
Reserve is now at its lowest since 1984.
so let me recap this for you as people
come to you and say there's more there's
more releases right now under Joe Biden
than ever well okay that's complete and
total horseshit it was for the first
year and a half we just went into why
there's been more oil production under
Joe Biden than any other president well
you know that's complete horseshit
that's because during again the first
year and a half it was a result of
president Donald Trump and then it
plummeted well a second a Keystone
Pipeline wouldn't make any difference
Keystone XL pipeline so we don't need to
do that okay great I'm glad that you're
happy for us to be dependent on Russia
with this Administration approving the
Nordstrom pipeline oh and I hope that
you're happy that we have now tapped
into our energy reserves to the lowest
level since 1984 which again puts us in
a more compromised position so that
someone might be able to take advantage
of us like who I don't know I don't know
hint someone Eric swalwell might want to
bang
any spy from any country yes let me go
back to one two ones that we said I'm
not gonna have him play it but Joe Biden
not only has he done all of that right
and that's bad enough that's enough to
destroy the Americans
every single person out there who goes
to the gas pump all of us
he said Saudi Arabia is going to face
consequences because of how they've
handled
Russia
he basically is saying it's not because
of their cut of oil production it's not
because of what OPEC has done American
people you hate Russia right well Saudi
Arabia they're friends with Russia
that's why they did this you know who's
not complaining about this right now
Ukraine the people that would be most
affected by Saudi Arabia partnering up
with Russia they are not partnering up
with Russia to do this I understand that
Russia is part of OPEC plus but the
president is trying to frame this as now
we have a common enemy right the enemy
of our friend over here right they're
hurting Ukraine who we want to help by
supporting Russia right that's dangerous
rhetoric for an election and I guess it
doesn't work on me because I don't like
anyone well I don't like any of them
either I don't like Saudi I don't like
Saudi Arabia I don't like Russia and I
don't like Ukraine the left are the War
Hawks now I have no idea what's happened
to society in the United States they're
the ones saying that we should be going
to war and now Donald Trump is tying
that in remember War for oil so can I
pardon my language I'm sorry [ __ ] is
code pink
they're when you're out there protesting
the White House the second we went into
Afghanistan where are you right now time
complaining that it was a war for oil if
we had oil here remember yeah and you
were advocating for drilling in Alaska
or Antarctica whichever one of those
places everywhere yeah
everywhere look a little
helpful uh it won't be when Skynet Falls
and Russia decides to turn it into a
nuclear Wasteland yes they put if you
fix it we can't complain yes
it's unbelievable to me that's
incredibly dangerous
it really is good what happens when you
make ice the temperature of the Sun
let's see yeah exactly yeah what happens
when Russia turns all of the country
into Superman's dad's bachelor pad yeah
it's gonna really feel like pollution
when there's a warhead the ghost this is
quite literally Mount trying to convince
all of you that we need to engage in an
international Conflict for oil and by
the way it didn't pass the sniff test
when we're talking about Iraq and oil
sure I understand no bid contracts but
again if you understand what happened
with desert storms you know what a war
for oil actually looks like if you're
talking about actually just taking
siphoning oil from a country it's
surround the oil fields surround the oil
reserves bring in air support don't let
anyone take you don't pack up your stuff
and leave
yeah in this case we're actually right
now you can see through the legislative
process approving International or at
least supporting International reserves
of oil while shutting down our own and
saying hold on a second the reason we
should hate all of these people is
because Russia oil Saudi Arabia oil we
might have to enter into a war why for
oil yeah but don't we have a whole lot
of that I don't know anything about that
it's all about Saudi and Russian oil
kids
you're an [ __ ] sir all right we're
gonna go do a review of creed uh I'm not
looking forward to this on the mukla
please share hit like comment below if
in comment which one of these was the
most helpful for you A lot of these
myths are going around every time I
receive one of these Washington Post
charts on oil production under Joe Biden
like Kool-Aid man through the wall
YouTube thank you very much not really
we hope that Rumble replaces you very
soon piss off
foreign
[Music]